all right the un's general assembly
didn't just lure our you know mumbling
bumbling blundering out of touch
commander-in-chief into New York City
it's also now reported that it attracted
scores of high-end escorts from around
the country and around the world who
made their way you know as far as Vegas
and Europe just to meet up with the
dignitaries anyway uh here now with
reaction he's the host of fox Across
America by the way big comedy special
Long Island October 13th Huntington
October 13th of the Paramount I'm
standing filming my one-hour special for
Fox Nation by the way three to five
thousand dollars a session with these
high-end hookers oh well you know what
we learned something though what now we
know why Bill Clinton was doing so many
events in town this week
like he's like okay donate to the
Clinton Global initiative and could you
pay me in singles you know what I mean
the only thing I would add okay again
I'm a former cab driver in New York City
this is absolutely a true story okay but
I would warn these foreign leaders to be
careful a lot of the women in this
neighborhood of Adam's apples uh I'm
just I'm just saying fellas there's a
fine line between Daisy Duke and Dylan
Moby does it matter what pronoun they
are no not at those prices it probably
now when you were a cab driver do people
come to town in New York and say uh
where could I go and and meet these
people you want to laugh okay not only
do they ask you that but sometimes uh
some of the women would offer to barter
for the fair you know but there's
certain things you don't want too cheap
in life you know what I'm saying like
everybody loves that ad for 50 laser eye
surgery
go what how did that conversation go
well they'll say like ah this is you
know 75 unless you want to take it out
and trade you know what I mean like I
actually said that to you oh yeah me I
mean because I look like the kind of guy
look at these guys look at the guys in
the back they actually said well I need
to work for that company I gotta drive
for that candy now well listen all I'll
say to this Sean is it's nice to see the
politicians screwing somebody besides
the voters how about that great answer
it's been a Wednesday he presided over
the senate in a t-shirt and shorts but
don't worry he says he will save
democracy and will wear a suit uh to
work if the House GOP avoids a
government shutdown now my question to
you first of all this guy is a mess oh
he's a big mess listen I I feel bad for
fetterman if he was any slower he'd be
president you know
it's the saddest part of that fetterman
video where he's trying to get out I-95
remember that he's like ah I-95 when he
finally gets it out Biden yells Bingo
you know it's a mess it's a it's a mess
but yeah he says he's going to wear a
suit but knowing him it'll be a bathing
suit like I don't even know is
embarrassing because it's the Senate
okay the United States Senate is now
saying hold us to a lower standard
you're supposed to dress for the job you
want fetterman looks like he wants to be
the lead actor in a rom-com called
Debbie does meth okay this is sad the
sad it's the Senate all right I got
another time so tensions are rising on
on the golf course yeah you have this
one golfer by the way appears to lose
his mind during an argument over an
alleged stolen golf ball take a look
this is the worst Happy Gilmore sequel
I've ever seen
oh no I think that guy's kind of
mentally ill and I am an expert on
mentally ill because I watch CNN all day
um Jimmy but I don't like I mean the
funny thing about it is you know because
you work out that was not a physique no
no flex if you're trying to scare
someone away like if you're trying to
get the ladies to walk away maybe you
know Jimmy phela oh thank you sir
all right that's all the time we have
left this evening as always thank you
for tuning in making this show possible
please set your DVR so you never ever
missed an episode of Hannity I want to
join our live audience show well it'll
be on Thursday the day after next week's
Republican presidential debate tickets
hannity.com they're free in the meantime
let not your heart be troubled why stay
tuned hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else